le mystère continue de planer sur la
disparition d'un des plus haut placé du
gouvernement chinois c'est le 29 août
que le ministre de la Défense lige
langue fou est apparu pour la dernière
fois en public son déplacement au
Vietnam le 16 septembre a été annulé
officiellement pour raison de santé
depuis Pékin garde un silence absolu
alimentant les rumeurs sur la tombée en
disgrâce du haut-responsable que sait-on
à ce jour du destin de lichenku ce n'est
pas la première fois qu'un haut
responsable chinois disparaît
brusquement des radars l'absence de
nouvelles de lit et d'autant plus
inquiétante qu'elle fait suite à la
chute cet été du ministre des Affaires
étrangères qui gormit le diplomate avait
lui aussi disparu des radars pendant un
mois avant d'être démis de ses fonctions
d'un trait de plumes le 25 juillet sans
aucune explication la chute de lichenku
constituerait donc un second revers de
fortune parmi les fidèles de oxygène
ping quelques mois seulement après avoir
été nommé mais ce week-end aucun indice
n'a été donné par le chef de la
diplomatie chinoise wanguy sur les 12
heures d'entretien qu'il a eu avec le
conseiller américain à la sécurité
nationale Jake solival une fois les
renseignements américains détiendraient
des informations rapportent le final
Times selon eux les chanku serait visé
en interne par une enquête pour
corruption derrière cette condamnation
une nouvelle vague de purge sévirait au
sommet de l'Armée populaire de
libération au total 8 au gradés de
l'armée chinoise serait visé dans cette
affaire les bouleversements de
l'organigramme militaire confirme qu'il
existe des frictions entre XI et des
hauts personnages de l'appareil
militaire en octobre dernier le 20e
congrès du Parti communiste chinois
avait consacré la main mise sans partage
de ksjin ping dirigeant le plus
centralisateur depuis Mao le prince
rouge en est persuadé la mise au pas des
forces armées chinoises fortes de plus
de 2 millions d'hommes passent d'abord
et avant tout par une guerre impitoyable
contre la corruption dans ses rangs en
2016 la condamnation a perpétuité du
général Gouh box Yong vice-président de
la toute-puissante commission militaire
centrale ouvrait une vaste campagne de
lutte contre la corruption au sein de
l’état-major chinois elle reste une des
priorités du troisième mandat d'oxygène
ping enfin juillet le commandant des
forces nucléaires du pays et son adjoint
était destitué pour avoir accepté des
pots de vin ces troubles dans les hauts
en militaires indiquent que la campagne
antique corruption menée depuis une
décennie n'a pas réussi à discipliner
l'Armée populaire de libération les pots
de vin lors des appels d'offres sont
monnaie courante malgré les doutes
d'oxygène ping face à sa hiérarchie
militaire son pouvoir demeure sans rival
estime lit donc Guillou spécialiste au
Hasan